fifteen years ago I thought that the
diversity stuff was not something I had
to worry about it was something and all
the generation had to fight for in my
university we were 50/50 male/female and
we women had often better grades so well
not everything was perfect
diversity in leadership positions what's
something that would happen naturally
over time right well not quite
while moving up the ladder working as a
management consultant across Europe and
the US I started to realize how often I
was the only woman in the room and how
I'm a genius
leadership is still is many leaders I
met so diversity as something to comply
with out of political correctness or
miss Kay's the right thing to do but not
as a business priority they just did not
have a reason to believe that diversity
would help them achieve their most
immediate pressing goals hitting the
numbers delivering the new product the
real goals they are measured by my
personal experience working with diverse
teams had been that while they require a
little bit more effort at the beginning
they did bring fresher more creative
ideas so I wanted to know our diverse
organizations really more innovative and
can diversity be more than something to
comply with can it be a real competitive
advantage so to find out we set up a
study with the Technical University of
Munich we surveyed 171 companies in
Germany Austria and Switzerland and as
we speak were expanding the study 2600
companies in five additional countries
around the world we asked those
companies basically two things how
innovative they are and how diverse they
are to measure the first one we
ask them about innovation revenue
innovation revenues the share of
revenues they've made from new products
and services in the last three years
meaning we did not ask them how many
creative ideas they have but rather if
this ideas translates into products and
services that really make the company
more successful today and tomorrow
to measure diversity we looked at six
different factors country of origin age
and gender amongst others while
preparing to go in the field with those
questions I set them with my team and we
discussed what we would expect as a
result to put it mildly we were not
optimistic the most skeptic in the team
thought or saw a real possibility that
we would find nothing at all most of the
team was rather on the cautious side so
we land it all together at only if
meaning that we might find some kind of
link between innovation and diversity
but not across the board rather only if
certain criteria are met
for example leadership style very open
leadership style that allowed people to
speak up freely and safely and
contribute couple of months later the
data came in and the results the results
convinced the most skeptical amongst us
the answer was a clear yes no ifs no
buts the data in our sample showed that
more diverse companies are simply more
innovative period now a fair question to
ask is the kitchen the chicken or the
egg question meaning our company is
really more innovative because they have
a more diverse leadership or the other
way around which way is it now we do not
know how much is correlation versus
causation but what we do know is that
clearly in our sample companies that are
more diverse are more innovative and
that companies that are more innovative
have a more diverse leadership too so
it's fair to assume that it works both
ways
diversity driving innovation
and innovation driving diversity now
once that we publish the results we were
surprised about the reactions in the
media we we got quite some attention and
it went from quite factual like higher
female share boosts innovation to little
bit more sensationalist as you can see a
stay-at-home women cost trillions and my
personal favorite housewives kill
innovation well there's no such thing as
bad publicity right on on the back of
that coverage we we started to get calls
from senior executives wanting to
understand more especially surprise
surprise about gender diversity I take
to open up those discussions by asking
well what do you think of the situation
in your organization today and a
frequent reaction to that is well we're
not yet there but we're not that bad one
executive told me for example oh we're
not that bad we have one member in our
board who's a woman and you laugh
now you love but he had a point in being
proud about it because in Germany if you
are if you have a company and it has one
member in the board who's a women you're
part of a select group of thirty out of
the hundred largest publicly listed
companies the other 70 companies are
just have an all-male Board and not even
one of these hundred largest publicly
listed companies have as of today and a
female CEO but here's the critical
important insight those few female board
members alone they won't make a
difference our data shows that for
gender diversity to have an impact on
innovation you need to have more than
20% women in leadership let's have a
look at the numbers as you can see the
we divided the sample in three groups
and the results are quite dramatic only
in the group where you have more than
20% women in leadership only then you
see a clear jump in innovation revenue
to above-average levels so experience
shows that and data shows that you do
need critical mass to move the needle
and companies like Alibaba JP Morgan or
Apple have as of today already achieve
that threshold another reaction I got
quite a lot was well it will get solved
over time and I have all the sympathy in
the world for that point of view because
I used to think like that too now let's
have a look here again look at the
numbers taken Germany's an example let
me first give you the good news so the
share of women who are college graduates
and have at least 10 years of
professional experience has grown nicely
over the last 20 years which means the
pool in which to fish for female leaders
has increased over time and that's great
now according to my old theory the share
of women in leadership would have grown
more or less in parallel
right now let's have a look at what
happened in reality
it's not even close which means I was so
wrong and which means that my generation
your generation the best educated female
generation in history we have just not
made it we have failed to achieve
leadership in significant numbers
education just did not translate into
leadership now that was a painful
realization for me and made me realize
if we want to change this we need to
engage and we need to do better now what
you do achieve in more than 20% women in
leadership seems like a daunting task to
many understandably given the track
record but it's doable and there are
many companies today that are making
progress there and doing it successfully
let's take a say pedis of your company
as an example they had in 2011 19% women
in leadership yet they decided to do
better and they did what you do in any
other area of business where you want to
improve they set themselves a measurable
target so that set themselves a target
of 25% for 2017 which they just have
achieved the goals made them think more
creatively about developing leaders and
tapping new recruiting pools they now
even set a target of 30% women in
leadership for 2022 so experience shows
it's doable and at the end of the day it
all boils down to two decisions that are
taken every day in every organization by
many of us who to hire and who to
develop and promote now nothing against
women's programs networks mentoring
strainings all is good but it is these
two decisions that at the end of the day
send the most powerful change signal in
any organization
now I never set out to be a diversity
advocate I am a business advisor but now
now my goal is to change the face of
leadership to make it more diverse and
not so that leaders can check a box and
feel like they have complied with
something or they have been politically
correct but because they understand they
understand that diversity is making the
organization more innovative better and
by embracing diversity by embracing
diverse talent we're providing true
opportunity for everyone thank you thank
you so much